further top story this afternoon an
urgent demand over our drought crisis
good afternoon thanks for joining us i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casa as
well nevada senator cortez masto is
stepping in and joining the fight with
the southern nevada water authority to
help find a solution to our water crisis
she is sending a clear message to our
neighboring states and the federal
government
all colorado river states to take the
actions that nevada has already
undertaken to conserve water an urgent
plea from nevada senator catherine
cortez-mastro on the drought crisis as
she is pushing billions of dollars in
aid from the inflation reduction act to
fight the uphill battle
i am calling for significantly stronger
federal action
from this administration to ensure all
states
are fairly contributing to water
conservation along the colorado river
the department of interior recently
announced our state will face an 8
percent cut in its annual water
allocation from the colorado river for
next year nevada has already been taking
steep measures to protect our water
according to the southern nevada water
authority it's not easy
our local elected officials have been
taking some very tough votes on golf
course budgets on limiting pool sizes
but it's working
this year alone
calendar year to date january 1 to today
our community has removed 5 million
square feet of turf it's measures like
these the senator says are the blueprint
other states need to follow she wants
the federal government to take a
stronger role by recognizing them and
implementing them extra measures are
also being taken for patrol enforcement
in the future we're going to be
activating our automated meter
infrastructure very soon and then we're
going to be able to see in real time
when someone's watering the wrong day of
the week whenever water in the wrong
time of day and ai can actually start to
generate those fee notifications
well thanks to the tight water measures
nevada has taken on this issue senator
cortez masto added our state consumes
the least amount of water than other
states along the colorado river we
reached out to senate republican
candidate adam lagsalt on this issue he
had no comment